Alright so here's how we're going to look at this. So as
you may recall, in this housing example. If we look at different
degrees of polynomials and how well they fit the data. Let's
look at the training error. The per example training error. So how
far off is it for each of the data points? And
as we increase the degree of the polynomial from constant to linear
to quadratic and all the way up to, when this case
order six, the error's always falling. As you go up, you have
more ability to fit the data, closer and closer and
closer, right? because, each of these models is, is nested
inside the other. We can always go back. If the
zero fits best and I give you six degrees of freedom,
you can still fit the zero. So, that's what happens
with the training error, but now let's use this idea
of cross validation to say what if we split the
data up into chunks and have each chunk being predicted by
the, the rest of the data? Train on the rest of the
data, predict on the chunk. Repeat that for all the different chunks
and average together. So, so I actually did that. And this is
what I got with the cross validation error. So there's a I
don't know there's a couple of interesting things to note about this
plot. So that we see, we have this red plot that is
constantly falling and the blue plot which is the cross validation error
starts out a little bit higher than the, the red plot that's
got higher error. So, why do you think that is Charles?
>> Well that makes sense right?
because we're actually training to minimize error.
We're actually trying to minimize error on the training set. So the parts we
aren't looking at, you're more likely to have some error with. That makes sense
if you'd have a little bit more error on the data you haven't seen.
>> Right, so, good. So, so, in the, on the, this red curve. We're
actually predicting predicting all the different data
points using all of those same data points.
So it is using all the data to predict that data. This
blue point, which is really only a little bit higher in this case,
is using, in this particular case I used all but one of the
examples to predict the remaining example. But it doesn't have that example when
it's, when it's doing its fitting. So it's really predicting on a new
example that it hasn't seen. And so of course you'd expect it to
be a little bit worse. In this particular case, the averages are all
pretty much the same so there's not a big difference. But now, let's,
let's look at what happens as we start to increase the
degree, we've got the ability to fit this data better and
better and better, and, in fact, down at you know say,
three and four, they're actually pretty close in terms of their
ability to, to, to fit these examples. And then what's great,
what's really interesting is what happens is now we start to
give it more, the ability to fit the data closer and
closer. And by the time we get up to, to order six
polynomial, even though the error on the training set is
really low, the error on this, on this cross validation
error, the error that you, that you're measuring by predicting
the examples that you haven't seen, is really high. And this
is beautiful this, this inverted u, is, is exactly what
you tend to see in these kinds of cases. That
the error decreases as you have more power and then
it starts to increase as you use too much [LAUGH] of
that power. Does that make sense to you?
>> It does make sense, so. The, the problem is that as
we give it more and more power we're able to fit the
data. But as it gets more and more and more power it
tends to over fit the training data at the expense of future generalization.
>> Right. So that's exactly how we, we referred to this is this
sort of idea that if you don't give yourself enough degrees of freedom,
you don't give yourself a model class that's powerful enough you
will underfit the data. You won't be able to model what's actually
going on and there'll be a lot of error. But if you
give yourself too much you can overfit the data. You can actually
start to model the error and it generalizes very poorly to
unseen examples. And somewhere in between is kind of the goldilocks zone.
Where we're not underfitting, and we're
not overfitting. We're fitting just right.
And that's the point that we really want to find. We want to
find the model that fits the data without overfitting, and not underfitting.
>> So what was the answer on the, housing exam?
>> Well, so, it seems pretty clear in this,
in this plot that it's somewhere, it's either three or
four. It turns out, if you look at the
actual numbers, three and four are really close. But three
is a little bit lower. So three is actually
the thing that fits it the best. And, in fact,
if you look at what four does. It fits the
data by more or less zeroing out the, the quartic
term, right? It doesn't really use the, this power.
>> Oh, but that's interesting. So that means
it, it barely uses the, the, the extra degree
of freedom you give it. But even using it
a little bit, it still does worse than generalization.
>> Just a tiny bit worse.
>> Huh.
>> Yup exactly so.
>> That's actually kind of cool.